let's go to our caller to the two from
the two one for area code who's calling
today from two one four hey David this
is Anthony is this me yes it is hi David
thanks for taking my call I'm a longtime
listener been missing since 2014 to
college and I've been a huge fan ever
since love it
so I'm an actor from Dallas I'm on a
film set right now actually just have
some downtime so I thought I'd call into
your show any is anything we would we
would know or um I'm awfully sorry I
actually can't get into specifics about
what it sort of secret projects like
these don't please don't know uh yeah
yeah yeah but but anyway um so I'm
really involved in the film world and
I'm a I'm aware that currently in
pre-production there I don't know if
you've heard about it there's a
miniseries that's an adaptation of James
kumys book a higher loyalty er you're
aware of that no I did not I don't know
who's playing me in it uh I don't know
probably Tom Cruise or something I would
say I would go listen if you have any
say shoot for either Joseph
gordon-levitt for me or or the guy that
played mr. Schue and Glee okay yeah just
make it I'll look into both of those
buddies unfortunately I have really no
say on it whatsoever I'm not involved in
that you were talking earlier on your
show about how you were wondering about
how it's possible to portray Trump in a
way that isn't parody you know it isn't
a comical because he's so ridiculous and
so it reaches how do you play Trump in a
straightforward way right and so the
actual play portraying Trump is named
Brendan Greeson I don't know if you know
that actor know he's playing Trump and
Jeff Daniels was playing Comey okay so
um I was on a live chat with the Young
Turks and I asked John iadarola about
what he thought of it and he said he's
just afraid that they're going to
present comeö some sort of heroic martyr
that's gonna be the point of it
especially because it's an adaptation of
his book right how do you how do you
hope that the miniseries will portray
either come--it romper what is your hope
for how it's going to portray event well
with Cole
I think he should not be glorified but
he should be listen there was something
Comey was fired he was the victim of
Trump initially and that doesn't make
him heroic or not heroic it doesn't make
the actions taken up until that time
good or bad in any way he then decided
instead of disappearing he would be in
the public and he would say things and
do things and whatever and you can say
that that has some degree of risk
associated with it but I think it would
be a mistake to glorify him in some kind
of deity like way as far as Trump goes
here's the problem I think there's two
options with how you portray Trump if
you play Trump in a fictionalization
true to what Trump has done it's going
to seem like a parody because it's so
insane
the alternative would be that you turn
Trump into a dark villain but that won't
ring true because Trump is not an evil
genius in that sense and that would also
not be accurate so that's a real tough
that's a real type of acting job quite
frankly yeah exactly it's gonna be
probably a career-making move yes my mr.
Griffin it's uh that that's something
that you know as an actor you try to UM
you try to find things in your
characters that people can relate to and
film sympathy for I was watching an
interview with the actor will raw star
who portrayed Lee Harvey Oswald and
killing Kennedy and he was asking about
how he was trying to make Oswald a
sympathetic character and that's not an
easy thing to do but he wanted to some
degree have you feel sympathy for the
guy with it without you know without you
know condoning his actions of course or
like thinking like oh that like I'm on
his side not no not at all it's just you
have to you know give the audience
understanding of where this character is
coming from and their decision-making so
and it will be quite a job yeah it's
it's a Haake Herculean task listen I've
got a run but I appreciate the phone
call and I hope to hear from you again
that does it for today sorry I wasn't
able to get to everyone I I rarely am
but we will take calls again